I have personally witnessed people in my
family have outright medical violence
enacted upon them and I'm not just
talking about neglect I'm talking about
organs being removed we've all heard the
benefits of yoga and meditation a reset
on the mat may be just what the doctor
prescribes some people just go well
whatever the doctor says I've got to do
because the doctors not everything and I
don't believe that they do behind the
medical celebrities of Deepak Chopra and
dr. oz is a contentious decades-long
strategy to promote alternative medicine
to the American public
it was my calling that's the easiest way
I can say it my journey began over 10
years ago my worlds became very dark
emotionally and it came to a point where
one of my doctors said if I did not
change my emotional state I was not
going to survive more than two years
I've always enjoyed interacting with
people taking care of people cancer was
one of the diseases I interested me the
most you know I wanted to be a person
that could heal people's problems
herbal ism means to use plants as a
modality for healing we could bathe in
them you can eat them you can drink them
anything you can think of whether
medical practitioners approve of
holistic healers or not there is a
reason why people seek them out I think
it's actually somewhat confusing because
it could be anything from a health coach
that got a online certificate over a
weekend to a medical doctor who has
extensive training I didn't learn much
about alternative and complementary
medicine in my training and I'm very
interested in knowing what it is that
draws people to that there I think are a
lot of misconceptions about holistic
health involves and I look forward to
being able to kind of enlighten some
people today about what it is that we
truly do
my name is Armand hoes I'm a
psychiatrist and podcast producer name's
Josh Mansoor I'm a cancer doctor
physician here in Los Angeles
I'm shadi I'm a folk herbalist and
educator my name is Jeremy Stillman and
I'm a hypnotherapist and life coach here
in LA I'm Christina Stefan and i'm a
holistic practitioner healer
hypnotherapist and breathwork
practitioner I'm shot Eva Dodd I'm an
internist Hospital doctor and
integrative practitioner in Los Angeles
and I have all of my holistic healers on
the left and can I have all my medical
professionals on the right I have had
bad experiences with Western medicine so
as a physician and being in the part of
what people deem as quote-unquote
Western medicine there's always going to
be a bad apple and there will always be
someone that has a negative experience
that's not to say that the whole thing
is negative when my son was young and I
didn't want to give him the MMR
vaccinations that was my belief that my
son was not safe to get that MMR vaccine
and I had to fire my son's pediatrician
because she looked at me and she said if
you're not gonna trust my professional
opinion you're stupid
and I transferred my child to the next
doctor and I said doctor what do you
think and she said don't do anything
where your heart is not in the right
place to do it
I'm a Western medicine doctor myself and
most of the negative experiences have
come about when I've been a part of on
the caregiver side and have taken family
to to doctors or hospitals dealing with
hospital staff has been pretty
traumatizing actually and knowing the
system knowing what needs to be done
it's very clear to me when things are
not done in the right way and I always
wonder if it's so challenging for
me as a physician how would a family
know how to advocate for their loved one
I have had personal experiences and also
personally witnessed people in my family
and in my community just have outright
medical violence enacted upon them and
I'm not just talking about neglect I'm
talking about organs being removed but
as a woman that has a chronic illness
I'm actually in contact with doctors a
lot and I wish I could report that I've
had positive experiences but I can't
think of a single doctor I've had that
hasn't displayed racial bias in a way
that negatively impacted me I would love
to see an integration but in the
meantime the culture and Western
medicine creates a space that's not safe
for me and given these bad experiences
I'm curious to ask you as physicians
where do you think the role of the
patient lies in terms of you know doing
our own research I tell all my patients
to bring as much research as they want
bring as many questions as they want to
me and there are situations that say
they want to bring a more holistic type
of treatment it can be integrated the
one caveat I would say to that is a lot
of times when folks that don't have the
background training that we have take to
the internet you know there's her Google
and stuff absolutely there's so much
misleading stuff out there while I
definitely also encourage research be
cautious about what you read
you can't validate everything that's
online you know as a person with a
chronic illness when I come into the
doctor's office sometimes I come as an
informed person and I feel like that's
not appreciated and I've experienced in
other countries that medical
professionals don't carry quite the same
arrogance I believe the other side
takes advantage of vulnerable people
yeah when you look at the way
conventional medicine is practiced you
see heavy amounts of influence on the
part of special interests and the
average person who's sitting down with
the physician they don't know what has
led up to that experience of them being
prescribed a medication they're just
going on this you know the this faith
that they have that they're going to be
taken care of I do have a problem with a
lot of holistic healers as they continue
to grow and how much they are taking
advantage of patients the oversight is
very minimal for some of these
practitioners who claim to be holistic
healers they're not held to any rules or
regulations and they are claiming to
know everything I think most of the time
if someone has a bad experience with any
provider it's because of the quality of
the provider not necessarily whether
their alternative or Western
conventional medicine I think that there
are times when it does come down to what
the patient you know their condition is
I have so many people that come to me as
kind of a last resort because they
weren't able to get what they needed
through Western medicine and sometimes
I'm not the first herbalist our
alternative practitioner they come to
sometimes they're rude by somebody that
has a better Instagram page or a better
marketing and I call those Instagram
healers not to be dismissive but because
there is a lot of harm that is done by
improperly trained holistic healers but
I don't feel like those people that are
taking advantage of those that are sick
are the issue I still believe it's the
medical system that has over time
suppressed alternative traditional
healers and because of the suppression
they've been driven underground
now it's harder to find somebody and
hold them accountable if they've done
wrong I think both sides can be quick to
dismiss the value of the other side
because they just don't understand
what's involved and I feel strongly that
really there's a time and place for all
of us but it's on the patient to do
their homework to know what is the
background of each practitioner you have
to think what their training is and
maybe you're asking the wrong question
of the person sitting up in front of you
having access to medicine should be a
human right the United States is known
for being a country where you can get
anything if you have the right type of
money but we know that's not true
because I can think of a number of
celebrities with lots of wealth and
access that almost died not for want of
money but just because of who they were
because of their background but there
are places where there is universal
health care and anybody has access to it
and they thrive because of it all right
I want to know why you guys instead Lord
I have something to say to that I do
completely believe in that but maybe not
in the States
because I feel you get what you pay for
here if you don't pay for it you're
probably not gonna get the best care but
in other countries let me tell you I am
believe it yeah I mean socialized health
care systems are enough a foreign thing
in this country you know we have like
the Veterans Administration that's like
the largest healthcare system you know
in the country and it's essentially a
socialized system Universal you know I
can speak to the level of care being
pretty good but to compare it to
something you might get in a Beverly
Hills private practice or something like
that it may not be quite the same level
so in terms of quality the facilities
the service and if that's what you want
you know probably to get that in a
socialized system yeah I think there's
no denying especially with everyone here
that we would want for every
to have health care I mean it is a right
of every person to be able to get
treated for it to help them that's not
the issue the issue is it takes so many
different other moving parts to be able
to make that happen the finances between
it getting payment for hospitals to stay
open employing the nurses the doctors
this isn't a simple oh do we you just
want every person to have health care I
mean come on of course but there are so
many other variables that people don't
understand that gets taken into account
I mean everyone's platform it seems
every politician goes oh we need
universal health care for all well if it
was that simple would be done already
it's not that simple I have witnessed
miracle healings miracles do happen
people do heal miraculously because of
belief system changes and that's what
hypnotherapy allows people to experience
as a change of a belief that has been
limiting - a change of a belief that is
empowering yeah I think there's also
certain situations all patients come in
that there are prognosis statistically
like you all are saying based on numbers
based on trials are more grave than
others sometimes they will be able to
respond that therapy and then end up
being this so-called miracle you're not
allowed to say miracle
no yeah it depends on how we're using
the word miracle or not I've trained in
something called functional medicine
which is an approach to medicine looking
at the root cause of illness and I think
the reason I enjoy practicing this type
of medicine because a lot of the cases I
consider almost as miracles the typical
patient that I see has essentially
failed conventional medicine I've seen
patients with MS who failed conventional
treatments and started doing yoga and
recovered from Foot draw I've seen
patients who were completely bald cut
out gluten and have hair grow back
had I not trained in this area I
wouldn't have believed it I've never had
someone come to me that was so hopeless
that I absolutely didn't have confidence
I'd be able to help them in some way if
they were outside of my scope they
wouldn't be with me
I heard you speaking about as a
functional medical doctor you deal with
people with chronic illnesses and
conditions those are the people that I
tend to work with and so if their hair
grows back or their information reduces
I see that as like a logical conclusion
to the treatment a key
I guess ethical principle that we abide
by which is non-maleficence
yeah do no harm but another one that's
really important is autonomy and that
you know speaks to what you're saying is
it's their body right it's their
experience and they have to do
ultimately what's right for them what
makes them feel you know good and healed
it's really got to be an approach that
probably integrates both sides I think
ultimately that's why we're here today
to come together and not be separated
from each other and work together we
were the most boring group